chers amis nous sommes au début d'un
long parcours qui va nous conduire
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle et
donc à l'alternance l'alternance tous
les Français la veulent ils la rêvent
même ce projet il est fait par tous il
est fait pour tous et il est fait avec
vous et je remercie encore celles et
ceux qui inlassablement ont contribué à
ce projet et les présents je le disais
ce matin ont toujours raison et donc
vous avez raison et ceux qui ne viennent
pas pour de mauvaises raisons ont bien
tort de bouder les travaux de leur
famille
politique
[Musique]
pensez penser
collectif penser collective de temps à
autre ça ne nuit pas ce projet ce ne
sont pas des paillettes ce n'est pas de
la poudre aux yeux ce ne sont pas des
mensonges ce n'est ni un casting ni un
opéra lyrique c'est pas de la poésie
même si aujourd'hui un grand poète est
décédé et c'est encore moins un concours
l'épine c'est le projet des républicains
disons-le c'est du solide et c'est du
sérieux ce sont des solutions réalistes
pour notre pays ce projet est une
rupture rupture avec le laxisme ambiant
rupture avec la société du chômage
rupture avec cette république des
parapluies où plus personne n'est
responsable de rien ce projet vient
répondre au défis gigantesque sans
précédent auquel la France doit faire
face maintenant nous vivons dans un
monde vous le savez où les menaces sont
gigantesqu et où les défis sont si
grands ou les incertitudes si profondes
la France elle est ballotée entre
l'affaissement de l'Europe les ambitions
des pays émergents la menace terroriste
et puis des millions de réfugiés sur les
routes nous subissons un monde qui
évolue vite plus vite que nous sous la
menace du changement climatique et du
choc démographique à l'intérieur de
notre pays le climat n'est pas meilleur
disons-le la France décroche alors face
à ces gigantesques défi les républicains
veulent réagir et remettre la France à
l'endroit remettre à l'endroit tout ce
qui aujourd'hui est à l'envers les
Français sont prêts à faire de la France
une économie aux avantpostes européens à
restaurer l'autorité de l'État à
retrouver la maîtrise de notre destin à
innover à créer à oser à inventer mais
aussi à protéger nos valeurs
républicaine et notre identité alors on
doit aussi répondre aux questions
immédiates qu'on nous pose lors
componose lorsqu'on parle de projet et
d'alternance les Français disent
pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas fait avant
il faut pas éluder cette question elle
est légitime et bien en 2007 entre 2007
et 2012 la France du président Sarkozy a
su faire face à une crise économique
comme jamais il n'y avait eu depuis les
années 30 et cette crise économique nous
avons su faire face avec une efficacité
tout à fait redoutable la France a
résisté la France a inventé la France a
proposé la France était là quand le
monde n'allait pas bien et celle de
François Hollande aujourd'hui alors que
la France n'est plus en crise cette
France là cette France de 2012 la France
de 2012 lors que depuis 2012 cette
France de 2017 bientôt l'année prochaine
ça aura été une France qui aura reculé
pendant 5 ans aujourd'hui les défis sont
encore plus importants que ce qu'ils
étaient à l'époque et notre réponse elle
doit être alors encore plus plus
ambitieuse nous devons aller encore plus
loin encore plus vite encore plus
clairement on ne peut pas se résoudre à
voir la France décroché nous allons agir
très vite et nous allons agir très fort
et puis on nous demande aussi allez-vous
faire vraiment ce que vous dites et bien
oui nous allons faire exactement ce que
nous dites ce que nous disons durant
toute la préparation du projet on a pris
soin de communiquer sur chaque sujet sur
chaque proposition l'exercice
d'explication l'exercice pédagogique il
est majeur lorsqu'on veut faire des
réformes et Madame elcomery s'en rend
compte car nous voulons dire les choses
avant pour les faire après chaque mesure
doit être réaliste crédible et
impactante je vous le redis nous sommes
prêts les projets de républicain ce sont
une réponse sérieuse avec des
propositions précises et cohérentes
alors à quelle France croit--on ne
pensez pas que la France de demain ce
sera une France qui aura une vision
totalement fermé reclu sur elle-même ne
nous replions pas ne soyons pas
hexagonaliste comme voudrai certains la
France elle est mondiale son message est
universel son destin ne s'écrit pas
seulement à l'intérieur de nos
frontières nous devons luiedonner de
l'ambition lui la dotter d'une vision en
Europe mais bien au-delà de l'Europe
elle doit être aux avant-postes de la
mondialisation sans se replier être
capable de se protéger et être capable
de nous protéger également du monde
c'est une France courageuse et
responsable la France à laquelle nous
croyons c'est aussi une France équitable
et solidaire qui réconcilie les Français
avec eux-mêmes les Français en ont marre
du deux poids de mesures et de ceux qui
abusent sans arrêt le système ils en ont
assez aussi qu'on oppose
systématiquement des Français à d'autres
les propriétaires avec les locataires
les producteurs avec les distributeurs
les fonctionnaires avec le secteur privé
nous devons réconcilier les Français
ensemble nous voulons une France enfin
qui renoue avec la croissance et avec
l'emploi et puis nous ne croyons pas à
la France du principe de précaution nous
croyons à celle du progrès à la France
qui encourage le développement du
numérique mais garantit aussi une
économie loyale entre les acteurs notre
projet est une solution à ces défis
auxquels nous faisons face d'abord nous
voulons revendiquer nos valeurs nous
croyons au travail nous croyons à la
solidarité lorsqu'elle n'est pas au
frais des générations futures nous
croyons au partage équitable mais nous
nous opposerons toujours à la
philosophie de la cistana et de la
desponsabilité qui fragilise les plus
faible nous voulons restaurer l'autorité
toute l'autorité l'autorité de l'État
est aujourd'hui disloquée le
gouvernement se couche devant les
violences et nos forces de l'ordre sont
à bout de souffle nous réaffirmons
l'autorité de l'État pour assurer
l'ordre et pour assurer la sécurité de
chacun notre priorité sera aussi
d'éradiquer le terrorisme islamique à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur de nos
de nos frontières nous voulons tourner
le dos à cette culture du Laxis plus de
moyens et de considération pour la
police et pour la justice et puis oui la
France a le droit de choisir qui peut
rester sur son sol c'est ainsi qu'il
faut bien sûr un Schengen 2 nous voulons
enfin repenser l'économie et notre
modèle social François Hollande a pour
EMI la finance mais aussi les
entreprises et visiblement l'emploi
contrairement à nos voisins européens la
France va mal nous avons perdu notre
compétitivité notre dette explose et le
chômage de masse perdure pour randiquer
le chômage de masse nous croyons à un
triptique de réforme la baisse des
dépenses publiques la baisse des impôts
et des charges et la réforme du marché
du travail alors au choc fiscal imposé
par les socialistes nous répondrons par
un contre-choc fiscal dès l'été 2017 il
est urgent de répondre à ce bol fiscal
des Français François Hollande nous
annonçait d'ailleurs cette semaine dans
les échos d'ailleurs dans les écho que
peut-être si la croissance veut bien
revenir il envisagerait éventuellement
peut-être et pourquoi pas de baisser
l'impôt sur les revenu mais il n est
d'ailleurs pas encore tout à fait
certain mais c'est pas grave nous nous
nous sommes clairs nous baisserons de 10
% l'impôt sur le revenu car il est temps
de rendre aux Français le fruit de leur
travail et puis on économisera 100
milliards d'euros sur le quinquena ce
qui est évidemment extraordinairement
fort en sachant réinvestir le champ de
l'économie et en sachant également
réinvestir le champ du social ce champ
du social qui est si prioritaire ça
passe évidemment dans le domaine de la
santé par une revalorisation de la
médecine libérale et par une autonomie
plus forte des hôpitaux publics et puis
les aides sociales elles doivent être
fortes elles doivent être justes elles
doivent être généreuses mais elles
doivent être aussi incitatives ainsi
nous créerons une allocation unique
plafonnée en fonction des revenus les
Français en ont marre de ceux qui ne
travaillent pas gagnent autant que ceux
qui travaillent nous lutterons sans
relâche contre la fraude qui mine le
pacte social et parce que nous pensons
que la relance économique ne peut que
passer par l'emploi nous refondrons le
code du travail plus de flexibilité de
liberté et surtout de bon sens sur taxer
par exemple les CDD pour contraindre les
entreprises embaucher en CTI c'est
simplement hérétique
nous ne voulons laisser aucun territoire
à l'abandon la ruralité est un phénomène
complexe et la ruralité mérite autant
que les villes les agriculteurs partie
intégrante de cette ruralité sont des
entrepreneurs et nous donnerons la
priorité évidemment à l'agriculture
française enfin nous soutiendrons
l'industrie et tous les fleurons
industriels nous croyons en une France
industrieuse et industriel cette France
des ouvriers des contrreemîtres et des
ingénieurs nous croyons aussi à la
transition numérique qui est important à
notre économie enfin nous voulons
maîtriser notre destin en maîtrisant
notre destin nous maîtriserons
évidemment l'avenir de l'Europe et nous
serons parler au monde tout entier avec
une défense solide n cher Philippe
Meunier avec une dépense défense solide
quand je dis défense c'est aussi dépense
d'ailleurs car la défense a besoin
d'argent la a besoin et nous nous nous
ferons cela nous prévoyons de donner 32
milliards de plus en cumulé en cumulé à
l'ensemble de la défense j'ai pas pas le
temps de de détailler durant le
quinquena nous voulons reticier un Pact
autour de la nation la nation c'est
l'unité des territoires la nation c'est
notre identité on doit imposer la
neutralité religieuse dans les
administrations les universités
publiques les établissements scolaires
les hôpitaux les entreprises aussi
l'école de la nation est enfin une
priorité majeure c'est la réussité
éducative aucun élève ne doit passer en
6e sans savoir lire et au fond il doit
même pas passer en CE1 sans savoir lire
on créera des classes de CP+ pour éviter
le décrochage au moment où le décrochage
se produit pu cette famille cette
famille qu'on aime tant elle est au cœur
de la nation à la fois la famille parce
que nous devons l'aider économiquement
mais aussi en mettant une ligne en rouge
totalement infranchissable autour de la
marchandisation du corps humain
c'est-à-dire la gestation pour autroyer
et puis nous aurons des institutions
renouvelées rénovées plus proches des
citoyens alors écout nous réduirons le
nombre de parlementaires tout en
revalorisant le rôle du Parlement les
Français veulent une République
exemplaire une éthique de l'action
publique et ils en ont bien raison en
conclusion nous avons construit un
projet qui est une alternance une une
alternance franche et claire avec la
gauche qui redonnera à la France la
place qu'elle mérite et donnera à chaque
Français le sentiment de vivre dans un
pays prospère dynamique à l'écoute de
leurs besoins les Français sont
exaspérés par ce gouvernement qui le
impose trop de règles trop d'impôts trop
de normes alors comme le disait le
président Pompidou arrêtez donc
d'emmerder les Français donnons-leur
leur chance faisons confiance à la
France et en français voilà notre vision
pour la France voilà le chemin qui nous
mènera vers l'alternance maintenant
j'invite chacune et chacun en son âme et
conscience à voter avec passion et
conviction pour le projet d'alternance
des
républicains